bonjour bruno bonnell bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en direct sur
air france pour parler de ceux de ce
beau film consacré aux métiers du lien
alors on attendait évidemment françois
ruffin sur cette question il a toujours
été très très très à cheval sur sur le
combat de ces femmes du lien mais vous
un peu moins expliquez-nous pourquoi ce
biais au un peu improbable entre vous et
et françois ruffin
et sa part tout simplement de du fait
qu' à part monopole de l'attention aux
problématiques sociales et au contraire
il ya une union même pour les pires des
oppositions aux autres sujets importants
ces femmes qui sont auxiliaires de vie
sociale qui son accompagnatrice
d'enfants en situation de handicap qui
qui s'occupe de nos bébés également
toutes ces femmes ont aujourd'hui un
rôle essentiel dans la société et donc
il faut pas regarder la société à
travers simplement du prisme politique
va regarder aussi ou au moment où la
politique peut aider à transformer ces
fameux métiers du lien c'est pourquoi je
me suis appliqué dans ce film et par
expérience personnelle également vous
avez aussi oui ceux qui ont voir le film
la découvriront mais j'ai des raisons
plus personnelles
alors j'ai côtoyé pas mal de
l'auxiliaire de vie sociale donc mais ça
je pense que c'est plus est plus dans la
scénarisation du film que l'essentiel
étant que il faut se concentrer sur
transformer ces métiers les valoriser
leur donner une carrière une
certification parce qu'on va avoir
besoin de 1 million de personnes d'ici
2050 dans ces métiers alors on va en
reparler mais avant je vous propose de
regarder justement un extrait de ces
femmes que vous avez rencontrées avec ce
passage qui illustre le côté multi
tâches finalement de ces travailleuses
et puis l'importance aussi qu'elles ont
aux yeux des personnes qu'ils
accompagnent en garde
en faire coiffer dans à l'arrière où
sont les côtés après
celle à l'arrêt par la wii d'accord
vous laisse je vais faire un petit peu
là pour faire dans votre chambre non
c'est vrai qu'on garde tous mes papiers
je comprends rien à fait moi voire
alarmant donc moi mais ça dépend combien
de candidats viennent il reste
22 minutes savez trés période des impôts
oui alors les personnes comptent sur
nous pour
les aider à remplir
châtenois la non mais c'est bon
vous pouvez la rente et la bo de gosnay
l'on nomme donc jules l'importance à des
tâches effectuées par ces femmes ces
femmes dévaloriser est-ce que selon vous
ça révèle finalement un certain sexiste
non je pense que l'on appelait que ces
femmes traditionnellement dans l'est
dans les familles traditionnelles
s'occupait des enfants des personnes
vulnérables
une des personnes âgées donc on en a
pris l'habitude alors ce sont de
véritables métier et c'est une vraie
différence entre s'occuper de ça sa
maman qui est âgée ou de s'occuper d'un
petit bébé et avoir le métier de le
faire et je crois que au delà même des
900 de sexisme il se trouve que 90% de
ces métiers sont faits par les femmes le
plus important c'est de les reconnaître
comme des comme des véritables
compétences et de donner du sens à ces
métiers à la fois sur le plan de la
rémunération et sur le plan du statut
alors justement la rémunération le
gouvernement propose 22 ans si je ne
m'abuse pour un de leurs
françois russian et peut-être vous même
vous préconisez plutôt 25 euros de
l'heure quel est le problème de cette
rémunération le temps de travail n'est
pas suffisamment considérer le mode de
calcul est pas le bon
en fait c'est surtout un problème de
deux modes de calcul plutôt que de
rémunération évidemment tout le monde
devrait gagner plus et le gouvernement
quand même a déjà fait des efforts à
savoir moniz et sur le territoire les
salaires des augmentations qui vont
entre 2 et 15 % suivant les les cas et
l'ancienneté donc et 240 millions
consacrés dans le budget cette année à
ces formations
mais ce n'est pas vraiment ça assez nous
proposons de travailler en tournée comme
les aides soignantes et au lieu de de
morceler la journée est de faire un
travail
hachez sur 12 heures dont effectivement
peut-être sept sont effectués ou cinq
sont effectués ont une force d avoir une
continuité dans le travail le matin ou
l'après midi afin de faire des métiers
qui est une qualité sociale et une
qualité d'entre d'une qualité de
relation soit plus approfondies et des
personnes âgées en clair des vrais des
vrais métiers quand des jobs et pour
cela il faudrait plus d' auxiliaires
alors finalement oui alors il faut plus
d'auxiliaires mais toute façon nous
allons avec le vieillissement de la
population mérite demande qui est de
plus en plus fort je le disais un
million de personnes en 2050 à la c'est
un choix de société on met des dizaines
de milliards dans la technologie que je
sus plan que je supporte je crois
effectivement qu'il faut le faire il
faut aller vers des progrès
technologiques c'est une des différences
que j'ai d'ailleurs avec mon comparse
françois ruffin mais à côté de ça on
doit mettre aussi beaucoup d'argent dans
cet investissement dans le lien social
parce que ça c'est une révolution qui
est tout aussi important que la
révolution technologique ben oui ça va
coûter de l'argent mais ça va en
économiser aussi beaucoup parce que
sinon ces personnes vont finir dans des
ehpad dans des institutions spécialisées
qui en termes de coûts de structure et
de coûts unitaires sont bien plus
considérables plus ces personnes qui
vont à domicile et c'est essentiel pour
le maintien à domicile des personnes
âgées est d'autant plus on a vu avec la
crise du colis d'un
oui oui le le maintien à domicile pour
des raisons psychologiques pour des
raisons évidentes de relationnel et pour
des raisons de coût et à la meilleure
des solutions au regard du nombre de
personnes qui grâce
grâce aux eaux progrès vieillissent plus
longtemps dans des bonnes conditions ou
dans des moins bonnes conditions donc il
faut vraiment que ça soit une révolution
sociétale en fait c'est ça l'objectif
c'est à la fois accompagné dé
l'évolution technologique dont on parle
autant par des révolution sociétale et
notamment ses métiers du lien qui sont
véritablement une une redécouverte de la
valeur de ces métiers d'humanité que
font ces femmes et peut-être amener les
hommes aussi vers ces métiers du les
enfants alors évidemment si si métiers
sont plus attractifs ces métiers sont
sur le plan du salaire souvent les
conditions de travail sont plus
attractifs on espère qu' effectivement
plus de diversité aujourd'hui je le
disais traditionnellement ça toujours et
qu'elle est femme qui s'occupait des
enfants ou des personnes âgées il est
temps effectivement que les hommes
puissent le faire en tout cas nous en
avons rencontré un certain manque très
minoritaire mais ce sont des métiers qui
mérite aussi d'avoir des liens avec des
hommes pourquoi pas si les conditions de
travail sont acceptables et et
attractive bruno bonnell justement d une
des députés ont déposé une série
d'amendements cette semaine puisque le
budget de la sécu et étudié en ce moment
pour pour revaloriser ces métiers selon
françois ruffin ça bloque toujours
regarder
tu vois ça fait deux ans que je me bats
lien avec le questeur de l'assemblée
nationale pour dire au moins que ici les
dames qui travaille elle pourrait être
payé le smic mensuel tu vois c'est quand
même pas la folie et c'est c'est une
baston et ça n'avance pas du tout tu
vois il te répondre que si tu me
rémunérer au dessus des minima légaux
c'est délicat juridiquement
ah bon est ce que ces amendements ont
une chance d'être d'être voté selon vous
bruno bonnell sur le cac que présente
françois d'ancinnes les femmes de ménage
et il le dit d'ailleurs à la fin du film
ont obtenu le 13e mois et en deux et des
conditions meilleures donc moi ça vaut
le coup de se battre ces amendements
débat zone chance de passer dans ce
plfss et le budget de la sécurité
sociale mais ils vont planté la graine
qui va faire prendre conscience que
c'est un sujet essentiel pour les années
ayant même si ces amendements ne passe
pas je ne désespère pas qu'il fasse un
petit peu changé les mentalités et
effectivement soit les graines du futur
sur une nouvelle considération des
métiers du livre
du coup après avoir été confronté à la
réalité de ces femmes dans le concret il
ya eu un projet un projet de loi qui a
été achetée est ce que cela vous a pas
donné un goût amer finalement
ben c'est toujours une déception de deux
vérins de missions parlementaires ont
proposé un projet de loi est de voir
qu'il ne rentre pas dans le calendrier
mais vous savez on n'est pas les seuls
il ya beaucoup de projets comme ça
qu'ils ne vont pas qu'ils n'ont pas pour
le moment où mais encore une fois une
démission des députés c'est aussi de
lever de soulever des problématiques du
pays qui touche
les femmes et des hommes de ce pays donc
moi je suis très fier a lancé denis
ondes avoir notamment réussi à cosigner
des amendements avec l'ensemble de la
majorité et des oppositions ce qui veut
dire qu'il ya une union nationale autour
de ce sujet donc c'est là que c'est
important je crois qu'il faut pas
regarder les chèques et le verre plat
verre à moitié vide moi je regarde
toujours le verre à moitié plein le
verre à moitié plein c'est une question
de volonté de continuer à remettre
l'ouvragé sur le métier pour que pour
qu'on bascule en termes de réflexion sur
ces mythiques ça ne soit pas simplement
des métiers de substitution ou pour
rester complément budgétaire marginaux
mais véritablement fasse une force
d'ailleurs une force qui permettrait de
donner du travail à des dizaines de
milliers voire des centaines de milliers
de personnes en france d'ailleurs pour
donner envie en termes de formation
qu'en est il pour amener à ces métiers
d'auxiliaire de vie est suffisant selon
vous non seulement pas c'est d'ailleurs
un nos amendements c'est qu'il faut
absolument les efforts mais des formes
et d'ailleurs initialement mais surtout
tout au long de l'heure de leur parcours
professionnel comme on le fait
d'ailleurs pour des aides soignantes
comme on le fait pour des projets pour
des infirmières pédiatres de parallèle
il ya les fonctions on va dire sociales
sociétales telles qu'elles occupent et à
côté de ça les fonctions sanitaires et
santé qui seront occupés par des
personnes qui désirent qui dépendent du
corps médical ou en tout cas qui sont
assimilés à des professions médicales
pourquoi ne pas mettre un parallèle
entre ces deux métiers et faire autant
de formations pour ses auxiliaires de
vie sociale que on le fait pour des
personnes qui parcourent qui vont un
parcours plus médicalisée ça c'est une
piste et dans nos amendements notamment
un amendement concerne la formation nous
recommandons une formation obligatoire
au bout d'un an d'exercice pour donner
une certification à ces personnes bruno
modèle le mot de la fin qu'est ce que
vous avez appris vous personnellement
avec cette mission avec ce film au
squash que ce que j'ai appris c'est que
les laits justement le basculement notre
monde on le regarde souvent à travers le
prisme technologique il faut aussi
regarder à travers le prisme de
l'humanité et ce qui est le plus
important c'est que ces métiers doivent
être valorisés en tout cas doit être
reconnu comme étant beaucoup plus
essentiels à notre à notre bien vivre à
notre mieux vivre que beaucoup de métier
que j'ai qualifié de gadget de
superficiel qui souvent sont sont mises
en avant dans nos sociétés merci
beaucoup bruno bonnell pour votre
témoignage ce matin dans la matinale
d'air france